george george
you classed up the joint today well we
tried to
how was quarantined with your children
because for a lot of us it was a real
adventure our kids are four and they
were two and a half when it started so i
didn't have to teach them trigonometry
at home
how is he as a teacher
oh he's great he's mainly teaching
pranks for the time being but we'll see
if it develops well i think those can
really pay off over time
how do you balance hollywood in which
you do i think it's probably like many
families where both parents work i'm
lucky because i have a very supportive
partner
and
we do move around a lot but we manage it
yeah and i feel very lucky
georgia mall hit the red carpet for the
first time in almost two and a half
years clooney directs pal ben affleck in
the tender bar and here's a fun fact
while they've both played batman they've
never been co-stars why won't you two
ever work on screen together what is the
deal here foot taller than me it makes
me look like you know mickey rooney when
i stand next to this guy i think it
would be too much sexy right for one
screen he's a one-time sexiest man alive
but not a two-time
i'm just going to say that out loud
2002's sexiest man ben arrived solo
earlier he and jlo held hands heading
into another screening in west hollywood
you guys kind of took over venice what
was that like the hooplan venice they do
a really nice job of making the event
feel special you know make it beautiful
elegant and beautiful
ben plays the bartending uncle to a
fatherless boy in the coming of age
story in select theaters december 17th
and on amazon prime video january 7th
sure enough the boston sports fan was
multitasking last night working the
press and keeping tabs on the big nfl
matchup patriots versus buccaneers and i
can't believe that you're not at least
checking the score or
hey listen i'm very dedicated to my job
and also you
have these phones that let you check
these kind of things you rooting for the
patriots or brady oh i can't answer that
that's that's the toughest question
you've asked
[Music]